hey how's it going good to see you so I
have to tell you I play this Marvel
video game with my daughter she's nine
and every time she picks the WASP first
she gravitates toward the watch talk
about the impact of your character and I
know that when you started it that was
one of the big goals right like get in
there kick a lot of ass and represent
yes yes
I
decided when I see little girls dressed
as the WASP for Halloween I get so
excited when my nieces have to pick an a
profile picture on their Netflix account
and it's me and
um did they have that representation
they have someone that they can look to
and pick that feels like they can
connect to and I think I'm even more
excited about where hope is going in
this next film because we have seen her
be powerful and Fierce and formidable
she's still all of those things she's
intelligent she's all those things which
is beautiful but she's also opened her
heart a lot she's had love coming to her
life through Scott she's had her father
her relationship with her father heal
and now she's had her mother come back
from the quantum realm so her heart is
pretty wide open which leaves room for a
lot of fragility and vulnerability and
I'm very excited to bring that color
because I think little girls need to
know that it's okay to stumble and fall
and make mistakes and to cry and to not
know what to do sometimes and then you
can still be powerful and amazing and
actually in makes you more powerful and
amazing when you feel those things and
then you overcome them that's that's
really where the heroism is and
everything that you just mentioned
that's happening in Hope's life makes
things very high for danger in this film
we've seen the Ant-Man movies become
more and more about family this family
affair Scott you know connecting with
people you connecting with your family
more can you tell me about how important
that is to get across and what that's
like to play with this cast
part of our brand so even though this
film is more epic and there's a more
sweeping Scope when it's going to be
larger and it's going to be there's
going to be more gravity to it if we
lost the family Dynamic if we lost the
father-daughter's relationships if we
lost all of that then I think our brand
would fall apart and that's that's what
it's hinged on that's what it's anchored
in and that's what I think people love
it for and that's what they come to see
is the grounding in reality because
we're regular people we don't have
natural superpowers we're normal people
so I think that seeing those
relationships drives it home brings it
into the living room where you can sit
with your daughter and you can feel that
between each other awesome thank you so
much